Speaker 1: Let's go next to Christian from
California, going to the opposite coast,
Christian from California. Let's hope you're
unmuted what's on your mind today. Hi,
David. Can you hear me? I can hear you fine.
Speaker 4: All right, so I have some questions,
I guess, about the way your show has been running
the past year. I remember pre election twenty
twenty. You talking about how day
one of the Biden administration,
you would be doing a lot of content. Focused on
pulling the Biden administration to the left and.
It seems that nowadays your content is. I feel
like I'm most of the time I'm at like a zoo,
but rather than looking at animals, I'm looking at
like. Things conservatives say, I was wondering.
Do you ever see yourself maybe getting
back to more? More video in segments
focus on implementing progressive policy.
Speaker 1: Yes, we continue to do a mix of things
during the covid relief bill ie we were to the
left of Joe Biden on infrastructure. We've been
to the left of Joe Biden. And, you know, every
day is just doing a mix of different things.
And I think we will continue to do that. You
know, my expectation, because this is the way
it's always been, is the mix will always be wrong
for a significant share of the audience. So I try
not to be guided too much by that and basically
just do the show. I feel like doing every day.
That's really that's really all it is. There's no
bigger you know, there's no there's no real big
influence other than what's the show I feel
like doing today. And that's been the guiding
principle basically since day one.
Speaker 4: Very strongly said,
thank you for your time.
Speaker 1: Thank you,
Christian from California,
very much. Appreciate it.